[Music]
teddy bear
[Music]
No
[Music]
I'm come to anything
[Applause]
get away
oh nothing happened what
yes ma'am I used to pay this Halloween I
choose trick I am so excited to announce
that my first google app game is on the
Play Store it is called sleep paralysis
as game experience simulation all about
sleep paralysis believe it or not I am
so so excited for this to finally be a
tangible thing that you can download on
your Android phone for those of you that
have been on this channel for a while
you know that I study computer games
arts and for last year's second year
project I work with two lovely girls
Tabitha and Tiffany and we work together
to make a Google cardboard game which I
had never done before and now you can
get it it is 70 P in the UK and around
about a dollar a euro in in other
countries probably a bit more than a
euro but it's not very much it's what
I'm trying to say and I was just
freaking love love love to hear your
feedback I have already had people
playing the game I am so so excited
about their reactions and the feedback
that they gave to me and the fact that
there's a lot of screaming involved when
people play it so I am very very happy
about that
C press is basically an experience where
you're still half in dream state but
you're half awake so you actually are
paralyzed because your body shuts down
your movements when you're in a certain
state of dreaming but your eyes are open
you're looking at your room and you
start to hallucinate what would be in
your dream
in the real room around you and
obviously that's a little bit freaky a
little bit stressful so it is more often
than not a terrifying experience one
that I have had many experiences of and
not just me many people so it's based
around experiences from real people real
stories yes I went on reddit but you've
had C crisis before right yeah sometimes
you'd literally just feel like you're
laying on the bed he can't physically
move and then the room looks the same
but you feel hands on you you feel like
breathing next to you you feel stared up
it's and you've got one of them that I
just realized you can't speak or
anything which is freaky so you've got
it right don't do it again I'm very very
happy with how the game turned out so if
you wanna check it out look in the
description below you can get it on the
Google Play Store and please let me know
how you find it but if you would like to
play the sleep paralysis game then I am
giving out five free codes because who
doesn't want free things so if you want
a free code then please leave a comment
in the comment section saying I want
game please for free yeah and then the
first five that I see I will email you
the code make sure you have your email
linked to your YouTube channel or I
won't be able to know where to send the
code to but it doesn't stop there
because do you remember a little guy
called Tara from who it is Tara yeah
that weird skeleton guy the creepy one
well he can now be bought to be put in
your home somewhere you might think why
would I want something creepy and morbid
in my house I've got him on my wall
that's actually that black in there but
that is terrible throw my bed every
night and you can buy him on duvets on
pillows on t-shirts on mugs on phone
cases all saw the Halloween seasons so
if you want to check that out do check
out my store which is also in the
description below there's nothing I
enjoy more than
sharing something that I'm extremely
passionate about with you guys this is
what YouTube is all about and sometimes
I struggle because I like to do more
than just video content and it's quite
hard to keep everything kind of in the
same place and to keep you guys up to
date with what I'm doing behind the
camera because as of now I'm back at
University for my third year making
another game this is gonna be another
horror game because I absolutely love
horror so I'm sure that'll be at some
point next year but if you want to
follow me and my university experiences
I will probably be uploading more about
that on my second channel there might be
some pauses in this channel just because
third year is hectic what to do and I
really want to invest a lot of time into
this next game because as you'll see
it's Google cardboard game was so cool
but there's definitely room for
improvement and this year I'm gonna go
ham on the game I'm very excited I want
to scare everyone is that my life box
there everyone I think this is I can
live with that yeah do you go check out
my second channel to see what I'm doing
behind the screens of YouTube please
please check out my game of the sleep
paralysis simulation I would love to
hear what you have to say about it
and thank you ever so much for all your
support
honestly it means the world to me and I
really hope you're enjoying this BuChE
season have a spooky day or evening
a little more like a meerkat I think I
think I'm supposed to be a zombie around
for a bit and like me can't get back up
when I do that no no it's correct